bueno esta medida implementada por el
gobierno realmente Es efectivo para
enfrentar la problemática del descenso
de agua en embalses y cursos
como te decía pienso que hay que ser
mucho más estrictos y más respetuoso del
agua nosotros estamos en Uruguay con
este paraíso en donde vivimos en
realidad
estamos respetando la bastante poco y
potabilizamos unos 700 millones de
litros por día para poco más de tres
millones de habitantes que somos así que
me da la impresión nosotros creemos que
no se pueden seguir regando las veredas
como alguien ve el Montevideo si si
viéramos la capital
regar veredas regar jardines llenar
piletas es absolutamente
lavar el auto cada poco muy muy se
acostumbra mucho aquí y eso tiene que
pasar de moda tenemos que empezar a
respetar mucho más el agua Bueno y qué
otras medidas pueden ser puestas en
marcha para hacerle frente a esta
situación
Bueno ahora el problema más grande
seguramente lo lo vamos a tener a nivel
de la nuestra propia seguridad
alimentaria nosotros nos movemos en el
ámbito de la producción de productores
de hortalizas y de frutas
Y lamentablemente a muchos productores
que ya se han quedado sin agua hace
tiempo para regar ya el problema no es
tener o no tener frutas sino que en este
momento hay plantaciones hay árboles que
ya se comenzaron a secar por lo tanto
nosotros tenemos que lograr el acceso al
agua potable
y o al agua de riego y esas dos
condiciones necesitan nada más que
dispongamos de los capitales para hacer
las obras las obras de ingenierías
necesarias Y eso sí después de hacerla
tener un respeto por este bien escaso
para la humanidad y no seguir
dilapiándolo como te he dicho ya por
tercera vez en estos pocos minutos que
creo que lo que estamos haciendo en el
Uruguay nosotros vivimos en el campo y
sin embargo reciclamos toda el agua que
usamos en nuestra casa
ni que hablar que es lo mismo que
tenemos que hacer en nuestras ciudades
aquí todas se tiran se vuelcan cientos
de litros por día de agua después de
potabilizar Al Mar al río de la plata al
Océano Atlántico digamos y eso creo que
ha llegado el momento de que estamos
proponiendo el mismo hace tiempo
nosotros como agrónomos y todo eso se
puede usar perfectamente para regar
plantaciones Aquí
van a producir el alimento o que que que
que va a estar faltando este año sin
duda en el